hey everybody i'm carla hall i am here
to give you a tip actually a pro tip i'm
going to do that again so i'm here to
teach you
a little bit shoot okay pro tip from
pros
okay yeah quit playing we're playing
hey everybody i'm carl hall
chef author and ex restaurateur and i
know a thing or two about the kitchen so
i am here to give you a pro tip from a
pro chef
[Music]
salt is a compliment but you can also
add flavors to your salt salt and sugar
are flavor carriers you can actually amp
up the flavor by taking a spice grinder
and salt or sugar and adding dehydrated
fruits and vegetables so we have salt
here i'm gonna put in a spice grinder
and then we're gonna add some lemon zest
we're going to make a lemon pepper salt
you take salt you take a spice grinder
you add like dehydrated strawberries it
could be peas it could be whatever
vegetable and pulse it in there and you
have a flavored salt you can also do the
same thing with sugar
if you have biscuits or something that
you want to put a little juice on top
if you have strawberry shortcake right
and you have that flavored sugar that
you can put into your whipped cream and
you can sprinkle on top sugar cookies
[Music]
so you can do even your salt with some
other additives we've got this smoked
salt we're going to add that in there
okay you can also add like even like if
it's dehydrated mushrooms into your salt
and pepper mixture imagine a strawberry
salt
what's
a strawberry sugar a pea salt okay i use
that on top chef just saying amp up your
game
[Music]